embarquement immédiat le nautic parc à
bougival a rouvert ses portes il ya
trois semaines
il propose pour les enfants une formule
anniversaire chaque week end
accompagnés de leurs parents les enfants
vont faire une demi-heure de zodiac sur
l'eau ils ont des petites énigmes à
résoudre
ils viennent pendant deux heures une
heure d'activité nautique sur le club
moussaillons et dans les eaux diack
abordé zodiac et puis une heure où ils
peuvent tranquillement goûter échanges
et les gâteaux les cadeaux et et passer
un petit moment sympathique
cet après midi là un anniversaire était
organisée parce qu'on a des affinités
déjà avec l'eau et puis on trouvait que
c'était sympa de faire faire une
activité dans l'eau enfants et de faire
découvrir aussi le nautisme certains
enfants qui n'ont pas eu l'occasion d'en
faire jusqu'ici pas sept ans ces jeunes
encore tous les week-ends de 14 heures à
17 heures des escapades en zodiac pour
les adultes sont aussi organisé une
balade commentée de trente minutes pour
découvrir le berceau des
impressionnistes les réservations sont
souvent complète depuis la réouverture
du parc d'activités nautiques
on avait déjà des gens qui nous a appelé
pour dire à quel moment on peut réserver
à quel moment on leur a donné le top dos
et voilà et avant nous faisions maximum
deux anniversaires par jour il ya une
telle demande qu'on est passé à trois
anniversaires pour les enfants qui ne
souffre leur est pas leurs bougies
il existe le club moussaillons
accessible de 3 à 12 ans cet espace
flottant de 200 m² contient une pêche
aux canards des bulles sur l'eau et des
pédalos j'évalue trampoline j'ai bien
aimé parce que j'adore sauté après j'ai
fait les bulles dans l'eau
il fallait tourner je connais cette
tournée nous avons commencé par la
balade en zodiac
nous avons fait une balade de 30 minutes
et après ma fille et l'a fait de la
trampoline et nous on a profité de ce
coin tranquille pour bord des boissons
fraîches
le nautic parc propose également son
circuit des impressionnistes pour
découvrir les grands noms des peintres
de cette époque une escapade commenté de
deux heures prochaines dates dimanche 13
juin
un bal sera aussi organisé dimanche 20
juin avec buvette